- Usually people are really confused
when I tell them what I do.
I tell them, like, yeah, I
own a fingerboard company.
Like those Tech Decks you
used to get in something.
Yeah, but professional.
Skateboarding makes me feel awesome.
It doesn't get boring.
It's always a challenge.
There's no rules.
Fingerboarding and
skateboarding both have that.
I started fingerboarding in fourth grade.
I had a lot of fun playing
with the Tech Decks
and then I wanted to kind of improve them.
A lot of times the screws would
come out so I'd glue them in
and just start modifying things like that.
And I just realized I could
make them better and better.
A lot of kids wanted to buy them
so I kinda put a name on it
and it grew into this
huge business over time.
There's hundreds of thousands of people
out there that are into this.
We are at the Flat Face
rendezvous location
in Dracut, Massachusetts
and it's pretty much a big building
filled with fingerboard parks
and I do huge events here
where kids fly in from all over the place
to come and fingerboard together.
When you go into a contest,
it's crazy cuz there's stadium seating
and there's everyone looking at you
and lighting and cameras.
My first few contests, I
got a crazy adrenaline rush.
Like, you don't even remember
the thing after you do your run.
I don't do any warm-ups or exercises
with my hands for fingerboarding.
Apparently some people do calisthenics.
The rules are pretty much
you want to use two fingers.
You'll have maybe 30
seconds or a minute or so
and you just do a run
and there'll be a whole bunch of judges.
They'll judge you on consistency, style,
the tricks you do and it's
like really high pressure.
You can't even really put it into words.
It's a crazy kinda feeling and atmosphere.
When so many people get together
from all over the world,
all over the country, and some of them,
it's like a really,
really big deal to them.
Like, that's the only thing
they want to do all year.
It just makes me super happy
because I can barely believe
that I'm the reason they're there.
Like, because of something that I set up
and that I'm doing.